bonjour jean louis bourlanges bonjour
ravis de recevoir ce matin sur lci vous
êtes député modem président de la
commission des affaires étrangères qui
travaillent toujours dans ce temps
suspendu puisqu'ils hier vous avez je
crois auditionné l'ambassadeur de france
en ukraine etienne de poncins
principe on ne travaille pas mais
l'actualité internationale est telle
qu'on était obligé de se réunir et
effectivement on l'a fait hier qu'à
recevoir notre ambassadeur à kiev et
j'ajoute que dans une interview ce matin
au figaro vous qualifié l'accord de
gauche dont on parle beaucoup ces
derniers jours l'accord à gauche de
capitulation devant mélenchon et
bérézina idéologique vous nous direz ce
que vous mettez dans la bérézina
certains disent que c'est une
clarification pour vous il n'ya pas de
doute c'est une catastrophe pour la
social démocratie mais d'abord l'ukraine
exactement dix semaines aujourd'hui qu'a
débuté cette guerre c'était un jeudi 24
février moscou a annoncé dans la soirée
que son armée avait estimé simulés par
dans des tirs de missile à capacité
nucléaire dans une enclave russe de
kaliningrad
par ailleurs poutine a aussi déclaré en
début de semaine jean louis bourlanges
les pays qui livrent des armes doit
savoir que les représailles seront
rapides comme l'éclair nous avons pour
cela les instrument adéquat est ce qu on
se fait peur en occident face à ces
menaces permanentes de moscou où faut-il
redouter que poutine franchit
effectivement à jour un cran
supplémentaire je crois qu'il faut
toujours se méfier de vladimir poutine
qui est un un personnage dominé je ne
dirais pas par sa folie c'est très trop
facile mais dominé par son orgueil par
la certitude où il est d'avoir fait un
mauvais choix et le refus absolument de
ce l'admettre de le reconnaître lui-même
avec tous les risques de surenchère que
ça implique or l'armée russe a révélé
ses faiblesses l'armée ukrainienne s'est
révélée beaucoup plus forte qu'on le
pensait et donc il ya une tendance
fondamentale des russes à se réfugier
dans ce qui est laure domaine de
supériorité c'est à dire les armes
horrible soient les armes chimiques soit
les armes nucléaires au mépris
d'ailleurs de la doctrine traditionnelle
de la dissuasion qui repose sur un
principe simple avoir des armes
nucléaires pour ne jamais avoir à s'en
servir et donc on n'a plus les russes
sont en situation de faiblesse plus les
russes sont dans l'impasse plus ils
brandissent une menace d'extension du
conflit face à cela je pense qu'il faut
faire preuve de sang-froid de modération
le président theodore roosevelt disait
au début du siècle dernier qu'il fallait
parler doucement et avoir un gros bâton
les américains ont un gros bâton nous
apportons nous mêmes notre contribution
mais je crois que nous avons aussi
intérêt à ne pas parler trop fort je
pense que la démarche du président
macron qui est de maintenir le minimum
possible de contact avec vladimir
poutine est plus raisonnable que des des
manifestations de bravoure un peu
intempestives comme on en observe de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique et de la
manche actuellement donc la synthèse
roosevelt c'est emmanuel macron à dubaï
joe biden qui quand même
à sur vous affirme à leadership et quand
même massif par des livraisons d'armes
qui fait qu' ils sont ceux qui ceux qui
arrivent le plus en appui quand même d
ukraine très très massivement sur le
terrain et l'europe qui livrent beaucoup
moins d'armes mais qui comme vous dites
parents doucement aboutir mais on livre
on livre des armes chacun chacun selon
ses moyens c'est comme c'est comme dans
karl marx chacun apporte selon ses
moyens nous nous sommes quand même
passés à des livraisons importantes
n'ont pas d'ailleurs parce que nous
avons tenu à renforcer
principalement notre effort mais surtout
parce que nous avons voulu l'adapter aux
changements de la guerre le début de la
guerre c'était une guerre un peu de
snipers en hausse en ce large c'est à
dire qu'il y avait une guerre de
mouvement mené par les russes et la
destruction des lignes derrière derrière
les les forces russes par des unités
ukrainienne très mobile très actif s'est
impliqué à certains types d'armes
c'était des snipers améliorer donc il
fallait avoir des armes antichars des
choses et c'est maintenant nous sommes
entrés dans une guerre qui ressemble
plus à verdun si vous voulez c'est à
dire deux lignes qui s'opposent très
fortement avec de forts duels
d'artillerie et c est là ils ont besoin
d'armes différentes et nous
contribuerons à les données comme comme
les américains mais évidemment je
reprends votre interrogation du début de
votre question qui aurait jamais douté
en tout cas pas moi que la sécurité
fondamentales de l'europe reste est
exercée par le la protection américaine
et que notre souci depuis une dizaine
d'années c'est de voir que les
américains se désintéresser de l'europe
ne se ne considérait plus la russie
comme une menace et ne s'intéressait
qu'à la chine et poutine de façon
extrêmement inopportune de selon ses
propres intérêts a ramené les états unis
à cette préoccupation fondamentale
depuis la guerre froide baguet certains
qui quand même sont très inquiets de
l'hégémonie
fantasmé ou pas des états unis des états
unis dix l'europe reste le vassal des
états où je sais pas je ne sais pas
pourquoi on dit cela c'est c'est le
temps a toujours été organisée de cette
manière là l'alliance atlantique aussi
du temps du général de gaulle on est
sorti du système intégré mais on est
resté fidèle à l'alliance ce sont les
français qui ont poussé les américains à
la fermeté dans la crise de berlin ce
sont les français qui ont été solidaires
des américains dans la crise de cuba
nous avons toujours eu une attitude
pierre acer mon vieux maître disait
l'alliance occidentale c'est une
alliance de peuple libre qui mutualisent
leurs forces évidemment avec un pays qui
a des moyens militaires et financiers
beaucoup plus important que les autres
est ce que vous le savez ou bas on parle
beaucoup du lundi 9 mai c'est pas si
c'est une construction de l'occident
c'est la fête de victoire nazie les
russes ont l'habitude sur les nazis les
russes ont l'habitude de la célébrer
avec défilé munich militaire face et c
est ce que poutine pour en profiter pour
prendre une initiative particulière
écoutez je ne sais pas moi je ne suis
pas dans la tête de vladimir poutine
heureusement la tête est très différente
par rapport à la scène mais je je je
pense que je vois pas très bien ce
qu'ils auraient à célébrer mais il faut
dire que poutine nous a habitués un très
très grand écart entre les mots qu'il
emploie et la réalité qu'il décrit à
dire pas c'est à dire qu'il va
transformer la victoire entre guillemets
de marioupol quand même une horrible
chose
en une sorte de progrès décisifs montrer
qu'ils en disent ont engagé dans un
combat fantastique avec les états unis
pourraient brandir les russies est ce
qu'il va leur envoyer initiative
rien je ne vois pas quelles initiatives
que l'initiative qui pourrait réellement
prendre un défilé militaire disait
que les militaires sur à marioupol cette
ville qui tu es vraiment si vous savez
une truite j'ai un ami qui est
latinistes et qui me citait assite à la
vie d'agricola talent et les germes à
10d des romains qui font une bulle qui
faisait une une politique en
germanie à peu près comparable à celle
des russes et il disait ou bi souligne
dean m fashion kw h m appelant il
transforme il appelle paix la désolation
quand on voit ce que sont les pays
prétendument arraché à l'ukraine le
donbass etc il ne reste rien il ne reste
pas un point b timents il ne reste pas
de population quelques vieillards qui ne
peuvent pas bouger et qui errent dans
les décombres en quête de nourriture
c'est absolument atroce on n'a pas les
deux jeunes si je ne sais pas s'il beau
et juste mais là c'est la destruction
véritablement d'un territoire peuplé qui
était transformé en désert complet alors
ça c'est quand même insupportable chaque
fois que les russes gagnent en ukraine 1
cm du territoire c'est un centimètre de
désert en plus il l'europe va prendre
une sixième série de sanctions c'est une
stratégie
graduelle l'assument enfin quels sont
les effets de ces sanctions répétées
voyez les centimètres gagnés par poutine
ça ne m'empêche pas de faire des
bonhommes ian pas grand chose je crois
quand même que le bilan des deux
premiers mois de guerre est absolument
clair c'est un échec complet
surestimation de la part de tout le
monde de poutine et de nous des moyens
russe au départ sous-estimation des
capacités de résistance de l'ukraine est
aujourd'hui une situation relativement
équilibré je ne dis pas que entre les
ukrainiens il entre les phares entre les
ukrainiens qui sont gonflés à bloc parce
qu'ils défendent leur territoire
c'est jusque dans nos bras égorger nos
fils nos compagnes c'est ça qui se passe
là bas c 'est une guerre de défense
avait guère de défense ça compte les
français sont battus à verdun parce que
c'était c'était l'ailé les paysans les
paysans ramasser la terre
cette terre-là il faut se battre pour
elle c'était leur terre les gens se
défendent pour leurs terres d'autre part
ils ont le formidable instrument les 35
milliards mis sur la table par les états
unis c'est à dire qu'ils ont un
équipement militaire parce que les
russes ont gagné la seconde guerre
mondiale faut jamais oublier qu'ils ont
gagné avec les russes avec les soldats
russes l'héroïsme russes mais aussi avec
les moyens américains et là on a les
religions et craignant mais encore une
fois les sanctions européennes en les
sanctions européennes
elles sont progressivement efficace à
condition de pas se tromper on n'aura
pas on n'aura pas à travers les
sanctions on ne peut pas avoir un
résultat immédiat ni même très rapide
c'est une lente strangulation de
l'économie russe c'est une asphyxie des
financements russe progressif et
deuxièmement ça ne se fait pas sans
effort le général de gaulle disait le
salut exige notre le nôtre le salut
exige la vie à la victoire mais le
succès coûte l'effort si nous croyons
que les forces européennes occidentales
peuvent se dispenser de tout effort pour
gagner cette confrontation vis-à-vis de
la russie préserver leur indépendance
sauver l'unité de l'union européenne
assurer la sauvegarde et la liberté de
l'ukraine s'ils pensent qu'ils peuvent
le faire sans effort ils se trompent
mais c'est juste ardent de demander un
effort aux français qui vont par exemple
par une exportation du sur le pétrole
russe part dans un arrêt des
importations du pétrole russe d'ici à
six mois produits raffinés à la fin de
l'année ça va encore alimenter
l'inflation on sait juste que ce soit
les consommateurs en bout de chaîne qui
sait seul par les consommateurs en bout
de chaîne c'est l'ensemble est ce que
nous sommes nous
européens de l'ouest est-ce que nous
sommes intéressés par la préserve
préservation de nos démocraties de notre
unité ou est-ce que vous nous voulons
nous aligner sur la hongrie par exemple
c'est à dire un pays qui se privent
progressivement de ses libertés et qui
est progressivement satellisé par la
russie savez moi je cite toujours le mot
de thucydide et s y était oui en fait à
s'y faire face aux grecs qui est la
devise de la revue commentaire qui avait
été fondée par raymond aron et qui est
dirigée par jean claude casanova il
n'est pas de bonheur le bonheur le
bonheur que nous aimons tous il n'est
pas de bonheur sans liberté ni liberté
sans vaillance leur aide est un art
protéger les français quand même les
moins et les plus exposées à ces hausses
de prix absolument message il faut y a
pas de vaillance jeu vous pourrez
ajouter un mot à la formule de thucydide
et dire il n'y a pas de vaillance sans
solidarité dont je crois effectivement
que l'on ne doit pas laisser les blessés
et les éclopés dans le fossé non il faut
s'occuper tout le monde et c'est un
grand devoir national mais je crois que
nos jours notre avenir en tant que
civilisation notre place dans le monde
ne le respecte nous inspirons tout cela
est en cause et c'est pourquoi je suis
très inquiet ddd et tensions actuelles
d'une partie justement à bien sa mission
pas un mot voilà merci pas un mot
justement dans cet accord
qui unit
la france est soumise avec les verts le
pc et le ps pas un mot presse sur
l'ukraine sur la russie sur l'otan non
mais cet accord c'est absolument au delà
tous est absolument minable c'est ça se
résume très simple je troque mes
convictions contre des circonscriptions
et je troque toutes mes convictions
contre quelques circonscriptions donc en
plus c'est un c'est un marchandage qui
est qui est idiot qui est il est
d'ailleurs je pense que jean luc
mélenchon a eu tort parce que il n'est
pas homme à à
à maîtriser sa victoire et il a voulu
vraiment humiliée les socialistes il y
est parvenu et je pense que de ce fait
cette opération n'aura pas le
prolongement politique qui en attend
dans l'opinion mais les choix
fondamentaux les choix fondamentaux des
socialistes ont été mises en cause à
travers cet accord les choix qui sont
faits depuis la guerre c'est un
socialiste ramadier qui a écarté les
communistes au moment de la guerre
froide ce sont les socialistes qui ont
signé le traité de rome guy mollet qui
assimile résonne c'est françois
mitterrand qui a animé avec force le
combat contre les fusées russes avec ce
fameux discours de bonne de 83 ça a été
la qui ont été constamment fidèles à
l'alliance atlantique à la construction
européenne et à l'économie de marché à
condition que l'économie de marché soit
corrigée par de profondes mesures de
redistribution
c'est tout cela qui est d'un trait de
plume pour quelques circonscriptions
quelques plat de lentilles vraiment
dérisoire qui est mise en cause donc je
comprends vraiment l'indignation de 15,9
de cambadélis et de quelques autres qui
disent mais que fait-on de notre
héritage mais cet héritage il a fait 1,7
pour cent la présidentielle les français
n'en voulait plus et mélenchon il
ramasse la mise si je puis 1,7 sur celui
qui actuellement je suis à chat
paris et je veux dire qu'on n'est pas
très séduit par la gestion municipale le
seul qui était un candidat socialiste me
1,7 en réalité une grande partie de
l'héritage social démocrate avait été
captée par emmanuel macron regardez les
fondements et lui le fossoyeur du parti
socialiste au mans c'est lui le
fossoyeur de manon il est pas le
fossoyeur il est le clarificateur ce que
hollande n'a pas été hollande a voulu
tenir dans derrière le même charles même
attelages des chevaux calais dans deux
directions différentes
un cheval vraiment mélenchonistes
extrémistes s'étaient les
les frondeurs de l'époque du parti
socialiste et puis la mouvance sociale
démocrate qui avait incarné pendant
longtemps par rocard ou par de l'or et
il a cassé là dessus il a cassé c'est
pour ça qu'il ne s'est pas représenté
parce qu'il ne pouvait plus tenir sont
son attelage est ce qu a dit emmanuel
macron c'est qu'il fallait faire la
clarté qu'on devait assumer les valeurs
de la gauche qui sont des valeurs de
comme d'un parti démocrate américain
c'est à dire accepter l'économie de
marché mais jouer l'europe et la
multilatéralité c'est une grande cause
de gospel multilatéralité par rapport au
nationalisme jouer la carte de deux lits
du libéralisme politique et ait joué la
carte du libéralisme culturel ce sont
trois valeurs de miel ça veut bien dire
que le parti socialiste il ne portait
plus cette ligne sociale-démocrate c'est
une clarification plus l'une mort c'est
ça je voudrais savoir si vous c'est la
mort du ps où c'est une clarification
jeu je crois que c'est c'est là c'est là
sans doute eu la mort du ps et je pense
que les hiérarques du ps notamment
fort prix du mal pour sa vision des
énormes en liquidant un héritage dont je
rappelle que pendant 50 ans les
socialistes ont fait fort pour aller
dans l'autre sens de mendès-france
françois mitterrand michel rocard
jacques delors et du côté vert dany cohn
bendit ont tous choisi le camp de la
modernisation a invité façon un peu
tortueuses pour mitterrand notamment
mais le camp de la modernisation le camp
de l'europe le camp de la sécurité
collective avec nos alliés le camp du
refus des dictatures et c'est ça qui est
braley pour rien jean luc mélenchon il a
fait une belle opération politique qui
peut devenir premier ministre écouter
vraiment je serais extrêmement surpris
que la vème république aboutissent à un
lider massimo primo ministériel
c'est quand même quelque chose que parce
que c'est le lider maximo hills
manifestement ils habitent les les
vêtements de castro de chavez de toute
une série de personnalités le le
président le premier ministre et désigné
par le président de la république
ensuite il forme un gouvernement les
ministres sont nommés par le président
de la république sur proposition du
premier ministre et ensuite il faut
aller devant l'assemblée en réalité
quand on regarde les négociations que
mène monsieur mélenchon on s'aperçoit
qui se bat pour avoir un peu moins de
200 de 200 sièges éligibles deux cents
sièges éligibles oui ça fait pas une
majorité ça fait une belle opposition
il y aura une fort belle je sais pas
mais forcément il y aura une forte
opposition de gauche parce qu'il ya des
gens qui répondent à ce souci de rupture
par rapport aux choix fondamentaux de la
gauche française et puis il y aura une
opposition d'extrême droite qui sera
évidemment beaucoup moins forte qu'elle
n'aurait été si l'extrême droite n'était
pas mêmes divisés mais y aura mais n'en
sais rien il faut jamais insulter
insulté a viré et présenter le choix des
électeurs mais je dis que dans l'esprit
même de mélenchon les calculs électoraux
qui sont les siens démentent son projet
politique affirmée il va d'ailleurs être
le chef du gouvernement il veut pas non
mais votre vie si ce qui n'arrivera pas
que ce pays ne peut pas se réclamer ne
peut pas se reconnaître sur les choix
fondamentaux qui sont ceux du néo
poutinisme donc bon pour vous dans
l'esprit de mélenchon il s'agit
effectivement d'être le leader de
l'opposition me croit pas lui-même
au fait qu'il gouvernera la france je ne
sais pas parce qu'avec jean luc
mélenchon qui était un personnage très
remarquable ayant reculé même en talons
moi j'ai de bonnes relations
personnelles avec lui et membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères et
courtois mais est il a énormément de
talent c'est mais il a une
caractéristique fondamentale c'est
qu'ils considèrent que toute défaite est
une promesse de victoires différer toute
promesse et une victoire du tout des
fêtes et dont il arrive à paris là si
vous voulez je crois que jacques duclos
qui a fait à peu près en tant que
représentant du parti communiste en 1969
un score comparable à celui de mélenchon
n'a jamais imaginé lui qui serait ni
chefs d'état ni premier ministre
pompidou
vous vous représenter l'assemblée
nationale n'ont écouté c'est un cétacé
est absolument aux discussions j'ai dit
j'ai dit dire 10 depuis le début je me
présentais pas j'ai mes amis comme on
dit sont extrêmement soucieux que je me
représente je leur ai dit que j'étais
peut-être prêt à le faire mais je crois
que les conditions ne sont pas remplies
donc je pense que je n'irai pas mais je
je prendrai ma décision dans les dans
les deux trois jours qui viennent et je
souhaite vraiment ne pas y retourner je
trouve que j'ai 76 ans je n'ai pas envie
d'être parlementaire de 76 à 81 ans je
trouve que le temps bien sûr le moment
la politique étrangère les
responsabilités et le débat public voyez
je suis encore un peu vifs
mais je trouve que c'est il ya un temps
pour tout juste encore un tout petit mot
en attend le nom du premier ministre
emmanuel macron prend son temps
confirmation que jean castex restera au
moins au plus tard jusqu'au 13 pourquoi
pas jusqu'au 13
il n'a pas trouvé le bon profil je n'ai
pas d'information ça le premier le
président de la république à son
chaudron personnel à l'intérieur duquel
il fait cuire sont ces plats et on verra
ce qui en sortira je crois que c'est là
le privilège du président de la
république de d'avoir le temps de la
réflexion le choix des moyens le choix
des hommes et des femmes
on verra ce qui aura ce qu'il en sera je
trouve qu'il n'a pas tout à fait tort de
prom sont en bas il le prend quel profit
politique moi je suis de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut un profil politique
je pense que c'est la condition pour
avoir et c'est un des éléments
d'ailleurs de la prise de décision
d'être candidat ou pas de la
réhabilitation du parlement moi je crois
qu'il faut absolument remettre le
parlement au coeur du système ça
implique une modification du mode de
scrutin et ça implique d'avoir en face
de soi un interlocuteur pleinement
politique ce qui d'ailleurs a été le cas
castex car contrairement à ce qu'on dit
casque et s'était abrité un responsable
politique de plein exercice merci
beaucoup jean louis bourlanges avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur l'antenne de lci
à bientôt quoi qu'il en soit et et